[Musique]
j'étais rassuré tout à l'heure mais
maintenant après sa présentation c'est
fou tout je suis plus du tout à l'aise
en tout cas je tenais à vous remercier
pour cette belle invitation
c'est un honneur de participer au tennis
c'est vrai que je n'aime pas du tout
être devant la caméra mais l'expérience
que j'ai vécue que je continue à vivre
mérite effectivement d'être partagée
alors le défi est que le défi reste le
même pour ce soir c'est comment parler
de mon afrique
demont bénin et de l'armée en un temps
très court et en allant surtout à
l'essentiel ça après des semaines de
réflexion de 8 mac psychologique pour
finalement aboutir à vous raconter une
légende dahoméenne elle est
représentative de du sujet que j'ai
traité tout au long de ces deux
dernières années et récemment à cotonou
alors il s'agit en fait on ne donnera
pas son nom parce que le roi et le roi
et vin des rois d'abomey est tombé
amoureux fou amoureux d'une jeune d'une
jeune femme mariée mais complètement
amoureux d'elle ce pour lui c'était la
femme la plus merveilleuse blonde la
plus belle la plus brefs mais comment
avoir sept puisque dans la tradition du
dahomey toutes les femmes appartiennent
au roi mais celle ci est impossible de
la voir parce que c'était une femme
mariée un de ses ministres les plus
importants
il a tout fait il a tout fait elle
restait juste la femme de son plus
fidèle ministre
alors il a trouvé l'idée ingénieuse de
d'envoyer ce monsieur à la guerre qui
dit va à la guerre 50% de chances de
revenir 50 % de chances de mourir
bien évidemment il a eu de la chance ce
roi son adversaire est décédé bon très
bien donc il était tout content l'uni
super
le boulevard est ouvert manque de bol il
a tout fait les honneurs
les fleurs les salamalecs tout ce qu'il
faut la jeune dame a juste dit non il a
posé son fils eh bien c'était non au fil
du temps
à force de dire non vous mais qu'est ce
que vous voulez c'est impossible
souffert jeudi après le roi à ccc dieu
que fin qu'est ce qu'il vous faut
le crâne de mon mari pour pouvoir lui
donner des funérailles dignes de son
rang très bien toute façon il est décédé
donc ramené mois le crâne ce monsieur
cochrane pu amortir les cérémonies fut
grandiose digne de ceux de ce monsieur
la jeune dame demande à ce moment au
moment des obsèques que la tradition
dahoméenne soient suivies à la lettre et
jusqu'au bout à savoir comme se doit
d'être enterré avec son époux vivante et
c'est ce qui a eu lieu
forcément puisque tous ses mandats au
met nous sommes au coeur du bénin nous
sommes au coeur des rois pour qu'elle
fut enterré avec son mari ce que je
voulais retenir de cette histoire et
vous en rêvez pour raison pour laquelle
on en reparle ce soir c'est cet état
d'esprit comme que l'on retrouve chez la
femme du lao mais j'ai les amazones une
fidélité sans nom une détermination sans
faille
il n'y a que la mort pour arrêter cela
et c'est cela l'esprit d'une amazone
qu'elle soit une princesse une jeune
fille une personnage et c'est l'état
d'esprit qui reste donc c'est ce que
j'ai voulu représenter lors des
différentes expositions c'est à dire une
détermination sans faille
le roi béhanzin d'autres rois bien avec
bien évidemment avant lui
ont réussi à utiliser militarisé ces
différents corps de métiers ils les ont
glorifié en leur temps mais c'est cet
état d'esprit qui est resté du début de
leur création jusqu'à la fin donc c'est
ce que j'ai voulu partager avec les
différentes populations qui ont
découvert les amazones du dahomey avec
les béninois au mois d'août et ce soir
avec vous voilà ce que c'est que d'être
là au meilleur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]